[Musik]
wozu gehen teenager in die tanzschule ja
gut um tanzen zu lernen aber wohl auch
um sich näherzukommen und genau das geht
gerade nicht bitte nicht übertreten
tanzen ja aber kontaktlos mit drei
metern abstand wie soll es da klappen
zwischen tänzer und tänzerinnen ja sie
muss sehr viel mehr wissen also
auswendig lernen damit sie auch das
macht deutlich welchen man kann viel
besser an sich arbeiten einfach an den
techniken und so war halt kein partner
der in irgendwie noch andere sachen
zeigt oder irgendwie noch andere
einflüsse gibt die solotänzer machen das
beste aus der situation aber von außen
betrachtet wirkt der schatten tanz dann
doch etwas herzlos
macht tanzen mit partner mehr spaß weil
man kann sich besser unterhalten man
lernt sich auf einer anderen ebene noch
einmal kennen drehen drehen drehen
drehen drehen drehen erst mal zum
fenster der tanzlehrer ist überzeugt
dass auch die reduzierte form des tanzes
funktioniert wenigstens in den nächsten
wochen die kennen sich die lachen
miteinander die schauen sich in die
augen da geht mal was schief dann lachen
sie und haben spaß es ist genug nähe
dann also und das ist ja nicht keine
dauerhafte lösung
das wissen die das wissen wir und
deswegen können wir das jetzt mal so
verschmerzen
der nächste kurs und shrek ein enger
paar tanz sind jetzt etwa corona rowdys
am start im gegenteil ehepaare die sich
schon viele jahre berühren
auch sie müssen allerdings auf die
abstands markierung achten dürfen aber
tanzen wie gewohnt
ohne tanz hatten wir echt entzog ihr
tanzen seit zehn jahren
es hat uns ganz toll da fehlt ja und wir
haben uns damit beholfen doch in unserer
großen diele doch aktiv zu sein
das ziel des trainings der winterball zu
weihnachten wenn er denn stattfinden
darf die tanzschulen sind schon froh
dass überhaupt wieder was los ist auf
ihrem parkett nach fast drei monaten
zwangspause
wir hatten zum glück ganz ganz viele
treue kunden die uns über die zeit
gerettet haben die weiter ihre beiträge
bezahlt haben
aber gerade große umsätze wie von
veranstaltungen wie unser unser gastro
umsatz und natürlich auch viele
kündigungen alleine wegen der angst die
uns erreicht haben da hat mir schon sehr
große einbußen von angst ist hier keine
rede mehr höchstens davor sich auf die
füße zu treten
ansonsten gilt das motto tanzen ist auch
in krisenzeiten unverzichtbar
[Musik]